I'm doing a thing called The Secret
Service which Matthew Vaughn and I are
correlating Matthew Michael created the
scanner British you know a 21st century
version of James Bond the idea of it as
like f James Bond's had you never really
see James Bond's family you know so FS
can a British super spike and I thing to
see his home life like what goes on in
the background we kick ass is that
unusual perspective on superheroes this
is doing the same for the Spanish onda
so you've got a gang who has all these
kind of things going on like The Spy Who
Loved Me can a lifestyle you know but
it's all parachutes off the sides of
mountains not like kind of thing but
then it comes back and he's got a sister
who lives in Peckham and she's got a
horrible boyfriend and everything you
know end of and she's got kids who was
in the London riots last year and she's
like you've got to help me I can't do it
with him he's 18 and he's just he's
going to respect for me and and that's
basically james bourne teaching a young
chav to be a gentleman super spy so it's
like my fear lady meets James Bond's
kind of thing so you've got a suave
super bright super spy taking this chav
and teaching them the fine wines and
gonna you know how to pick a good suit
and we're to get a good haircut and
tunneling a man a gentleman by the end
of the movie makes the up and a bag Spy
Who Loved Me style plot them done
together you know my god it sounds
absolutely amazing it's gonna be good
the books I know the first two of the
sex sessions at out just now and there
they've gone done really well I'm really
happy with him the guy who drew it's the
guy who co-created watchman Dave Gibbons
who's my hero III wrote the fan mail
when I was 17 and shinobi working with
him is so exciting and I tell him this
all the time and he's so embarrassed
about it and I still have the letter
that he sent me back I actually kept the
letter when I was 17 and so what I asked
who worked with him when / 17 and you
know 25 years on it's great actually
getting a chance that's incredible
thanks so much for talking too small
you